I'm a rabbit I only jump one inch yeah
you're kind of like hey you're kind of
like a little a hamster oh hey what's up
fellers oh hey hey guys how's it going
[ __ ] you wait hello wait wait everyone
shut up okay
yak jump wait I have to turn up my sound
because it's adorable but okay and Mark
is this you then over here that's me the
[ __ ] wait are you guys closed like a
billion over here wait turn right we're
over here at the green thing wait order
that we can make a lamb wiggle and we
make it let me tell you no no no no no
no no towards the bottom no way okay
well that's it go raise I turned right
yeah not [ __ ] oh yeah not you you
were like it look at go right okay okay
so was that was nearly cute but [ __ ]
slow yeah yes we are I think that's part
of the whole thing oh you don't all this
someone else here
oh okay [ __ ] Bob Lee fine wait there
but their pasta I'm drowning oh are we
supposed to go towards the building or
is that going to kill so I'm gonna go
towards the building all right Bob you
do daddy
obey I am I just hear understand oh my
god the building like a cow pig I'm just
gonna saying much about been gone
there's an ominous no hey oh my god is
everything I do kills you what guys
Isabella's balance oh we need hugga [ __ ]
we need to cry and hug it over on this
side hey guys get over on this side I
know why do we need to crash it because
it said you need to crash through this
game but unhappy I open the happy
dropship we're all gonna die see whoa
okay what what do we do what do we get
ring ringing bring me all that [ __ ] into
the until green box
[ __ ] murder you oh okay give me a
basis Christ obey me okay hey doesn't go
where do we bring it in the green box
right there doing okay no no no I'm
doing I only carry up to three items all
right oh look right click got it got it
okay thank you thank you shot you know
what money for you
wait are you Oh we deposited something
for no auto pay we probably shouldn't do
that Hey we demand fair pay and hair
wait hang on hang on right right right
wait please I don't know zero what is
mouth sorry sorry sorry sorry
oh I think I'm hearing a missile s god
oh sorry
don't you hang on I'm looking it's
happening can we have some obedience
payment overlord my skirm I'm already
mad at you something I it's really
terrifying that it looks like you have a
face to Diddy's and a dick to the gun is
your dirty God you got even closer on
the side I didn't do that you ran into
the electrical things i how do I [ __ ]
give you money what do we what oh oh hey
wait hey who's this hey Neil here it's
me it's at you that's you oh gee but
what I'm good money for you no no stay
still stay still I figured it out money
for you now you have money maybe you're
white I do a $37 there's someone on the
ground chose me for you don't get it
Jack I gave you money
drive-by $114 threw in $15 dropship all
right get the dropship get the dropship
stuff and bring it to Bob ah I look I
know how to give you money now bring it
to Big Daddy ball my God look at all
these free right there I'm bringing her
here good boy
[Music]
everybody you know I'll put some money
down for you good job good job everybody
thank you boy there's some money over
Nord Bob there you go there you go
feller
hmm any more you oh thank you no right
there if you would please
yeah we're bringing butter you know
carrying [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
bring that here every plane got my
[ __ ] past I was right yeah I gave you
money I give you an utterly buy [ __ ] you
don't buy em I got em I buy it
oh you buy some with our money
it was right no I have my own money
sighted yeah we have money too yeah
so I wasn't gonna say this until I had a
really substantial lead your goal is to
take over this tower for me just FYI
well yeah we can't get close you have to
walk in the front door sneaky sneaky
like I don't know that luckier than that
okay look wait don't hear it Christ we
should crash the dropship everyone
crashes prices [ __ ] this don't let me
show you miss resources [ __ ] it crash
the dropship I'm sitting here damn a
resource Oh
holy oh my god what have we done I don't
know I'd like no money anymore
yeah what the [ __ ] alright alright
alright Bob tell me what I'm supposed to
know basically every button except for V
is murder and you hold you hold V to put
little pointers on the map and to give
out money to people we don't seem to do
that for me Americans oh yeah it might
have been see it might have been so or
floatin see oh you're awesome all right
I think you look any moment whoa Bob
yeah did you guys strap my ship Hey look
get that stuff I'm back in control I'm
not gonna you I'll give you money
okay or I will give you many money Bob I
am a benevolent Oh
Laure I did not you got too close to the
laser thing Bob which means you killed
me
a winter date we have these metal body
in money what I have an obedience collar
do you need money
um you could put the collar on that'd be
fine okay it's already on I got it wait
who's this who's this person doesn't
have a collar
who the [ __ ] is that you you I'm coming
I need an obedience collar I'm dropping
off Dori I'm dropping off don't kill me
don't kill me okay all right
God you guys I'll give you money thank
you
can a money you gotta give thank you you
gotta drop me [ __ ] hey who's this who's
that here who is that [ __ ] with no
obedience collar who are you I will
talking and drop saying we can't get
that oh sorry I'll put some more I'm
rich so it's fun coming back yeah all
right thank you
I verified in color I put it on wait I'm
the one that's far away I have a collar
on don't kill me
I bring you resource I agree I bring you
everything you want I give you bet three
better all right we are going to eat it
how do i how do I pick stuff up okay
there you go
I don't know how to do anything here but
don't take that is fat why what did I do
I want to know what happened wait Amy
[ __ ] oh oh my [ __ ] oh yeah oh no oh
god this is cured I'm on it
I have an open collar doing here I'm
doing that I'm doing you should I love
I'm going that person ain't have a
collar that have a collar there was no
collar around her give me your damn
collar you're calling in the machine you
dumb no I didn't I didn't have one off I
just deposited my collar I'm sorry I'm
sorry Overlord see honey he's a betrayer
Oh money
Jackie boy in the worst Overlord
routine ah don't kill I've got goodies
for you kill a friend Eliza be good here
I'll finish the job I'll finish the job
that this traitor was in trouble he was
paying you look
oh [ __ ] snacks auto-pay sucess how'd you
do that Bob probably much money yeah I
took a substantial lead before I told
you guys how the rules of the game sorry
okay nothing can be purchased until the
dropship is purchased oh okay yeah how
do you earn money if you can't get a
dropship yeah I don't have $1500 well if
you let me take control I'll buy a
dropship since I'm rich haha I knew
someone was going to be all right mark
so you got to buy a dropship first but
you know I do that money for that
I don't you think it's that was rough
yeah you know why you've got we got 1800
why are you guys like you guys need to
put on your obedience collars I'm
working on it I'm working on I just
deposited mine did you in which
depository I'm right here I'm right here
where I deposited it adjust very cool
okay actually you guys I see you where
you guys going who's trying to sneak in
hey you're gonna order stuff or what how
do I do it on up you pit the numbers and
then and you have to buy a dropship
version of your screen but then you hit
the numbers that it says you go okay got
it drop ship on route yeah go into the
purple flame it gives you like money
okay wait I see shoes over there who's
over there huzzah jacket I think you're
going crazy mark no no no no no I know
there's treachery I know this treachery
I don't upon to the collars keep the
collars on mark can you buy the a collar
I'm in the dropship you may feel ooh
there you feel discomfort pain bunny
Pryor all right everyone everyone
everyone
oh hey collar give me that I can't pick
it up in the dropship
hey should we crash this [ __ ] no no
mark let's crash this [ __ ] watch
you guys I don't understand this case
when you're when you're the overlord you
passively get money but you can send a
$300 or same thing ish hey I all I
learned something else yeah
depositing corpses hurts you robot wait
what oh I'm at negative $1,500
oh my god rocking chair jack let's crush
it let's crush it quick come over here
[ __ ] this drop ship on your head ah God
all right we better get me some money
because like I feel like I learn I put
my collar on this is fine yeah sure okay
how are you hiding in that Bush without
being a bush I see you have auto-pay on
or what are you gonna pay me for this
[ __ ] I don't know I'd have no money how
can I pay know that of course
hey let's go I'm doing are you doing are
you doing I see you in that Bush no my
god yeah horses nice you guys can watch
the Fox stage that's [ __ ] christ oh
my god oh gosh drops a pod is now in
charge oh [ __ ] that's my yeah good good
I like this okay alright refresh this we
could wait twenty seconds otherwise
alright okay alright right everybody up
somewhere we got a guy on the left side
I got it you can do it whoo I got over
thanks guys no yay Bob is king No hey
well coming in and coming in hot there's
a bunch of money on the ground everyone
be cool put your colors on a roll Murad
I got I got it my colors on calls on
don't kill what always offers doesn't
have a color goes on doesn't have a
color collars on no I can't pick it up I
know what Bob I'm gonna scout for you if
I see people coming at you I'm gonna let
you know how's that that sounds
every Bob sure Bob I think kill him
first
no yeah that's not always the right hand
man who usurps you no no no no no come
on now come on now come on guys come on
guys
now we've nothing left to get like when
someone's coming in Bashan coming in Bob
someone coming in ha ha ha ha there your
function come in I [ __ ] dare you not
even try I'm not gonna bring you all
you're doing anything no no Bob I had a
caller you were carrying a corpse no I
wasn't God Almighty
oh hey don't bang you guys you just have
to not be a scrublord yeah dude yeah all
right
why did you do that because I are we
crashing the fish let's crash this [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] do this there's a lot of
fuel that's probably there's a dropship
bring me stuff I can't see where I'm
going
all right coming in coming in with
supplies high drop coming in with
supplies with socialize there's a body
weight there's a bunny in the bush right
here what someone's standing back here
up to the look over here there's a bunny
in the bush right next to me that red
bush okay
right there there's a bunny on you he's
[ __ ] hiding I'm being good see look
God [ __ ] what have you coming for me I
don't trust you no no no no it's fine
Vittorio will find it on tutorials are
for [ __ ] and Luger I get back whoa I
was given something close yeah wait I'm
gonna be your scout I'm your scout I
love you why are you throwing your drop
shot well that sounds like the truth if
I've ever heard it it's okay waited
they'll kill that thing we don't eat him
I have items on that boss [ __ ] I love
you have items you see me I'm a squeaker
I have items where who who's down there
I can't show you any more no no your
buddy
anyway and you're fine it's fine way to
[ __ ] pilot well yes so many nothing
happening just relax you waiter
oh Jesus all right so what here's here's
the deal guys I'm gonna place lights so
that he can see us better so that we can
obey him better coming in hot
all right
don't kill me Bob don't kill me I'm
placing lights for you look I should
have bought some colors I'm an idiot
look look I'm putting lights down see
where I am I'm over to your left
I'm putting a light down right here Wow
no hang on set it up and there we go see
you got right now eyes I'm going to say
you own another yes wait here yeah yeah
wait yeah yeah wait Bob follow me I'm
coming on your left I'm gonna come close
but I'm not gonna get too close I just
want to light by you so you always see
this spot right about comb-like there
whoa oh whoa whoa I'm gonna take I'm
gonna shoot close to you I'm not gonna
shoot you I just want you to know every
encounter Bob Mon I love me most there's
that good light you're a good little
bunny good light do I get a reward wait
Bob reward me I don't use this you yes
me
there you go hey the audio pay is
cranked up right now so if you guys
looking really good really blast yet
what's aggression did you dress this
[ __ ] [ __ ] it get over here who's don't
see trashy Bob I believed in you and you
know it [ __ ] you honestly uh [ __ ] you
alrighty money what the money thank you
watch my rabbit wait items don't serve
wait here a dog Wade's a bastard he
kills these other reason I thought okay
I want to pay you I think it's already
on whoa like I hate Lund that bunny just
literally burned alive right next to me
I don't have no idea why
Oh sucks to suck for that guy doesn't it
oh gee
don't catch that horse ain't earning
that is on fire guys don't keep walking
into the fire well I wanted to life
alright I bought a bunch of stuff on
this next dropship okay Wade Wade you
just ask invoice only how to turn on
autopay right yeah dead bot just said
wait a little prestonby four times what
I know what's up there you go alright
there you guys go
I'm traveling so I've already drivin I'm
grabbing it doing weight if you
endlessly kill us we're obviously not
going to help you hey me I did right
there honey is that [ __ ] yeah good
[ __ ] love mone come on nice drivin
way less money than us no because you
just cranked the way up
ah no our take I was trying I'm just
gonna [ __ ] steal your thing and you
had autoplay on so I what happened
I press would be why would you blame us
but I trusted you and you told me about
the D I didn't tell you about the D was
the bond it wasn't a soprano shout out
to see I mean Robert wait you're really
ruining this game by being stupid
how do I turn I don't know hey if we go
up a must be done right no no no we
should all just continue to get lots and
lots of money for me who this is oh I
don't have anybody
oh my god rabbit was approaching me I'm
gonna steal your auto face hey you asked
for money kill Bob he's headed back
towards Helena anyway I'm the only one
with an ax I got in this sock for wait
here [ __ ] fum you also suck the way down
there sorry steam so my days are over
Lord I am okay I have my collar on wait
wait I put my collar on good I'm doing
it I'm doing it right who is trying to
approach me no one is my auto-pay you
[ __ ] at all I knew I was where Jack
is
Jack I'm right here
and this one jumping up and down and say
green things okay my jack I help you
remember remember that I helped you jack
don't move I'm on that bush my bad buy a
collar on don't know you do but you were
still hiding bottles off Martin items
off if you bring me a quarter when I
kill you if you bring me sass I kill you
if you bring me a lovely nice shake how
do the drugs to you
we're coming in hot boys what are you
buying uranium
okay I'm washing every last one of you
like a how holy shish a lot of [ __ ]
you want okay yeah right now Otto pays
up
Otto pay higher good Otto pays good
Otto pays a tattoo chunker oh [ __ ] so my
auto paint Bob not me that's for sure
[ __ ] you nope I told you I'm watching
look this this herd is the good bunnies
herd yeah look I'm gonna create an auto
page just a little more auto pays up
yeah even more yeah what is it now set
three whatever that mean I would love
some more auto pay yeah it's good nice
good little good little Bonnie you can't
be my [ __ ] I see your [ __ ] we are good
funny I don't believe it
good bunnies you know mark there's a
couple of it were not being good bunnies
yeah it never ends Jack this is our life
from now my god there's a 40 minute
countdown or or four if someone gets to
ten dot Noah's which I'm very close to
uh-huh
yeah Bobby want to win okay I'm trying
make sure no one's stealing my money
then shoot me over Lord your follow
you're fine I'm watching I'm watching it
other places to deposit stuff it all
that light what are you doing I thought
I could do plug didn't get money oh okay
he's stealing the light that I put down
did you buy more that Mart yeah I bought
one for you yeah oh yeah yeah I'm gonna
go to another depositor just make this
yeah does another day here Oh what god
damn hahahaha
ah wait is your auto-pay still set to
like 500 man everybody was happy I'm
being a good bunny it was when I was in
charge everything was a [ __ ] utopia
way would I be under the pretense that
everything's going to be good you guys
are going to get paid there's lots of
stuff coming on the dropship it's going
to be a good time what what is going on
the dropship Mike sir
oh god master good stuff is you got a
isolate Bob he's gonna win yeah he's
gonna win he's very close I'm not gonna
win which is Bob what over far left kill
everybody just in case also I'm missing
two bunnies so I'm going to be
overthrown very soon no we're in the
important [ __ ] right now
well your callers on business [ __ ]
creepy my [ __ ] goddamn you run where's
that my home my obedience collar on I've
got the obedience collar on up and I'll
bring the pay up for you Morrow yeah
thank you
Thanks oh sorry I didn't pay you oh no
there you go there we go okay I'll give
you a bonus tiny mark you'll turn it
other two one oh thank you general you
know what it was on zero you piece of
[ __ ] oh well as if I'm gonna get you
anything anymore [ __ ] you
yes lucky you know what [ __ ] you all
right you little piece of [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah yeah mystical maniacal monkey
bastard what how about this yeah that's
that
that's good that's fair I'll take that
back good oh oh whoa oh yeah it's fire
waiting hear that what the hell happened
hey crash hey hey hey no no no I was
just looking at the carnage there's so
much [ __ ] over here come get that elbow
that's right to say yeah you've got your
life back you got my collar on I've got
my collar on I'm being good job I'm
being a nice bunny you guys over here
out I'm watching you
I see that you're doing good work you're
doing good job I'm right here I'm right
here I'm right here it's cool it's cool
chill chill boss
Bobby Riley okay let's fire up a crane
Bob there's not as much
stuff over here there's only two pieces
and I'm afraid if I give you that one
it's like it's not a corpse it's a piece
of wreckage but I don't want you to be
scared and be thrown off by it you know
what you could eat since you were nice
about it you can go get it
okay all right it's not a corpse that's
where Hey Hey we had to get up here
somehow
well maybe should've crashed the [ __ ]
dropship like an [ __ ] yeah guys maybe
you should listen to our boss he's a
good boss he's gonna night as boss you
know what just because all of you lied
to me and none of you are getting items
I mean my hello hello right now I see it
I see it I see it all right oh there are
more items over there I didn't know
there was more you want me to go over
there boss or you want me to stay here
yeah mark you can go over there there's
a bunch of items over there all right
why disobey the overlord musik erm
Boutique er well there's so much [ __ ]
here it's about to win and we can end
this [ __ ] nightmare yeah I want this
to be over just do your jobs a little
bunny rabbits oh yeah whoa I got it all
right I am a benevolent god
auto-pay is up to maximum heart I'm
calling in a ship I'm spending all of my
money on [ __ ] you don't need gonna be
the rhythmic dropship ever in the
history of ever I have no money I just
want to be thought okay is literally as
high as it'll go
I just drag the [ __ ] I think you guys
walked into a mines yeah there's three
mines from a drop zone - yeah there's a
lot of my mines - where the mine we're
all down one there all the way from that
drop zone don't walk a straight line
damn it make your way all right musique
herb whoa
Oh
[Music]